before we start this video I just want
to give a big thanks to our sponsor
audible audible has the world's largest
selection of audio books and audio
entertainment including audible
originals audible originals are stories
created exclusively for audio and you
have documentaries and it has scripted
shows that are exclusive on audible
honorable members can easily exchange
any title that they don't love at any
time and members can keep their
libraries of listens forever even if
they cancel start listening with a
30-day audible trial choose one
audiobook and two audible originals
absolutely free visit audible.com slash
straight Keeney's or text JK news to 500
500 you know what's important here at JK
news is freedom of speech freedom in the
media and we want to be able to say
whatever we want so on audible I just
downloaded this by Mark R 11 it's called
on freedom of the press and it's pretty
crazy because news reporting today is
being destroyed from within by the
journalists themselves
you just got to download it and figure
it out yourself but it's crazy another
thing that I really love about audible
is if you're an argument with someone
and you need you to prove a point and
someone says something inside the audio
book and you want to just take that
small little portion that makes you go
aha you can do exactly that by taking
that small portion and sending it to
them so you could win that argument so
go try audible today go to audible.com
slash JK news or Tex JK news to 500 500
the link is also in the description
below go there today audible.com zashiki
news thank you clickety-click it baby
[Music]
Endicott News admitted by Yanks a
cosmetics company that came under fire
for writing fake Sephora reviews has
finally settled its terms with the FTC
they [ __ ] all over Sephora and the
reviews they [ __ ] no oh they didn't they
faked its mate reviews oh I see their
competition they wrote how do you hire
people like this on Amazon or whatever
how do you hire people like this I need
some stuff to get boosted higher oh well
done Yelp do it all the legal oh is it
like is it like Adam Amazon reviews and
all that stuff no so this is on Sephora
so this company it's a it's a skin care
company called Sunday Riley I love him
Oh feels really good really it's by this
woman named Sunday Riley just named
after her yeah yeah that's about as
traditional as it gets when it comes to
naming a business yeah so then these are
some of our products most makeup brands
are that yeah Cosmetics make a lot of
money is there a mr. Sephora mr. Sephora
or a Miss Sephora it's a for our family
name oh wait no her name is Cindy rose I
think support is a big cosmetics company
right but maybe when it's good job job
big but when it was founded I was
thinking but you never know anyway the
point is like a Miss Calvin Klein and
she instructed her company employees to
write fake reviews about its products on
sephora.com and even gave a detailed so
there was this email back in July 2016
that the CEO wrote to her staff
directing them to create three accounts
on sephora.com registered as different
identities and then they also said
requested that other Sunday Riley
skincare employees also post fake
reviews endorsing their brands products
and the email included a step-by-step
instructions for setting up new personas
and how to use a VPN that's where they
[ __ ] up their identity
paper trail yeah and then so they are
employees to focus on certain products
and to always leave five stars when
reviewing Sunday Riley skincare products
and to dislike negative reviews and like
they wrote specifically if you see a
negative review and all caps dislike it
and after enough dislikes it is removed
this directly translates into sales how
did this leak out and it's it's an email
like they put it on you'll need a
whistleblower to go hang out look at
this email whistleblower [ __ ] leaked
this [ __ ] out disloyal [ __ ] or someone
that's already honest answer don't know
what's wrong you know like I'm gonna
take $10 an hour [ __ ] this Jacob me and
Joe asked anybody do anything illegal it
still wouldn't leak out cuz we're
everyone's tight and Lloyd you in stores
well don't hang on Sundays you know
Riley Sundays you know what's funny is I
expect this from all small companies not
something as big as a friend well no
they did it this makeup company so
Sephora so I was a bunch of makeup
brands like a retailer oh it's like a
department store for all the makeup
brands yeah oh I thought they had their
own brand too we do but and they sell it
just like cuz it's all like CK Prahalad
they got their own brand but they also
saw everyone else's [ __ ] too yeah
also the Sephora store isn't just also
for products also they packets multi I
get it so they'd Sochi so her brand is a
small brand that's now like shell yeah
it's been a long did you see it
yeah they going to support that's like
having a target site yeah and if target
is carrying a product yeah I love when
people fight like the light bulb goes on
and then they explain in their own words
I'm like yay learning habits
exactly I need to vocal I mean you're
you know yes you were more tolerant to
getting paid [ __ ] money you could have
been a teacher huh I know I remember
what I said I wanted to be a high school
counselor as a backup career and you
laughed at me I did that for you
yeah she will not forget that I was
raised by a very unforgiving man all
right would you want a backup career and
when you don't need one no I said when I
was originally like well I mean now Oh
in the beginning yeah in the very
beginning I was like I want to be an
actor but if that didn't work out my I
would want to be a detective or high
school counselor
detectives better I didn't laugh I
didn't like to look at blood or murder
so then I was like maybe high school
counselor then I was like maybe I'd end
up getting murdered by a troubled teen
oh [ __ ]
so then I was like I guess it's just
acting for me wow she's perfectly not
crazy
very normal you could have just
detective eyes parking valet parking
violations that's true well you know
what I know it's a violation it's not
subscribe to this YouTube channel so if
you're here and you're not doing that
you better get up to code okay and I'll
find out who you are oh yeah go through
the IP addresses no we could talk about
your anyway so the company's founder and
employees they're saying that they have
to see is saying that they're in
violation of two violations so they say
one is making a false or leading or
misleading claims that the fake reviews
reflected the opinions of ordinary users
of the products and to deceptively
failing to disclose that the reviews are
written by Miss Riley or her employees
so this whole thing here the they ended
up agreeing on a settlement but it's not
concrete yet but it has been talked
about now how this settlement is pretty
much a slap on the wrist and saying like
all right the FTC is telling them saying
like all right just don't do it again
what should happen to them you can get
regarder business so they're saying here
like a deception yeah yeah so they're
saying that um people actually believe
the reviews yeah like I do that like I
read all the reviews on all the
different brands before I'm like okay
I'll spend $80 on this cream cuz that's
like $80 it's been on a cream like
they're expensive items you know what I
look at I look at the most reviewed and
the most star because what I kind of
expect the manipulation and buying you
know that stuff to happen so I just look
at if they can maintain
hi star rating with high volume of sales
it's probably a popular product and I
just I just don't click on those and
then go to all the one star reviews and
decide if that problem is B no it takes
too much time did you guys yeah what's
the difference between this and
politicians with fake accounts did you
guys hear about Mitt Romney no so he had
a fagelah man yes so he is a fake he's a
senator in Utah he had a fake account it
is some shitty name too when you hear
the name you're like what the [ __ ] call
me it's like buster
Mick Mick man good you're like what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so he was busted
basically praising himself on his
Twitter account Kevin John that does the
same thing so yeah it's like hey Mitt
Romney how come you're not doing a bunch
of senators how come you not doing this
[ __ ] and he's like well Mitt Romney is
loser
well yeah what's funny because he's up
there and when you catch people up there
doing [ __ ] like that your life and you
find out how insecure they are just like
they they're all like the rest of us
like flawed people who don't have all
the answers
go figure but that's what's so [ __ ]
funny about this [ __ ] so when I hear
about this and I hear about a [ __ ]
senator doing it I'm like where's the
slap on the rest of the [ __ ] senator
that's true okay now they're saying here
that this this settlement sends a wrong
message to the marketplace
which means like dishonest firms may
come to conclude that posting fake
reviews is a viable strategy given the
proposed outcome here so they're saying
that what they should do is the FTC
should seek monetary consequences for
fake review fraud even if the exact
level of ill-gotten gains is difficult
to measure yeah they should make it
expensive to do it yeah because fake
reviews distort the market so and reward
rewarding bad actors and harming honest
companies is is making the problem grow
that's what people do on Yelp all the
time to is like you know friends and
family come in and they'll do do a five
star review for the brand-new grand
opening and I expect that [ __ ] to happen
on all that happening when it comes to
big scale like that I'm like all big
companies doing that
when I was interning at Universal Music
um like one of our tasks as interns was
to go into forums and talk about how so
when we had never even heard the album I
keep going there like wow who else is in
love with this my favorite tech is
whatever but we were like when I was
really broke like when I had like 89
cents in my account I would go on
Craigslist and they would hire people to
leave five star reviews for like 25
bucks and I would make like you know
fifty bucks we're leaving two reviews
but you had to like and there were
certain bullet points you know how like
you have to hit certain bullet points so
I need to make it sound organic so they
had to approve it's like a brandy yeah
uh-huh for a brand deal for like just
people that are anonymous see what you
you do that you did that but you still
read the reviews I know I totally
reviews because of that that's why I'm
saying it should be wrong because an
intern about saying you bad for it I'm
just lucky you're bad for it though not
even a good or bad thing I like it when
you're you're in a restaurant review
thing and you I've been to a restaurant
before where I talked to the owner and
they had like this broken English and
then you read the reviews the restaurant
and it's the same broken English the
same way to this function to this [ __ ]
and all seven of their reviews it's an
Italian restaurant that sounds like an
Indonesian guideline so that that's so
[ __ ] ready I don't know I expect a
lot of manipulation in the market always
I already come into it with you know I
can't believe and on top of that you
know how weird people are and like their
perspective is so I can't believe like
their experience would be my experience
dude Wall Street Kingdom you can
manipulate the [ __ ] out of markets yeah
you get caught doing some [ __ ] nail
review thing and you're going down
that's what i'll yeah i read i do read
reviews if i could find something that
is either what I'm looking for if I'm on
the fence of yeah but recently I was
trying to buy a wetsuits and I know
flying off the show yeah I know my head
is
a little bit larger in proportion to
probably what normal people little bit
it's putting it slowly dad aware of my
size well get her to push you out yeah
so I would read the reviews and see if
anyone had any tight head issues or
whatever then I can see okay because
that's probably that's so specific that
the [ __ ] Revere's probably wouldn't
write about that but if someone was like
he have a pretty large head and this is
what's who fit me perfectly
I'll could cool this this thing applies
I met no I just end up buying two wet
suits and I'm waiting for them to come
in and when I try them on then I'll just
be killed no would you leave a review
saying this one truth of heads
I'm so [ __ ] lazy I've never left a
review for anything Emily I did for my
air conditioner guy because he came out
oh yeah you have done two hours yeah oh
and we're [ __ ] was like in one a day
weekend my air conditioner guys this
Russian dude way if they kill it I'll
leave a good review but I've never left
a bad review oh yeah I have it would be
a good review be like this fit my big
fat head but that's actually that's
actually bad for the wetsuit cuz that
means it'll make proportional size
things I mean like if it fit me oh you
don't want to do and I have a gulabi pop
afraid not the right that's they should
they should probably adjust yeah what I
think of you I think of a lollipop for
sure just super skinny big head
did you win people he's more of a Lego
than a lolly
if we were to go to your mom and be like
you know Bart's heads big would she
immediately look at the ground I'm like
dad I think I only have one kid thinks
I'm perfect must kill my grandma because
of that they're like you might die if
you have this baby she's like [ __ ] it
I'm doing it cuz his head was so [ __ ]
big we should go up to Bart's mom with
the camera and be like yo Bart's got a
big head and then just place that music
[Music]